Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Melichia Mann.
Ich bin auch diese Station aus der DSL-Bender Arsthetik.
Ich würde heute mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegesprach führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne, natürlich.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben oder etwas nicht verstehen,
können Sie diese jederseits stellen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Felix.
Breitling.
Können Sie bitte nur nach einem Langsam und durch die Wüste wieren?
Natürlich Breitling.
Sie kennen die Uhr Breitling.
Das ist eine bekannte Marke.
Das ist Bertha Richthaarzt.
Emil Ida Teodor.
Ludwig Ida Nordpol Gustav Breitling.
Breitling.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 59 und werde bei 60 Jahre alt.
Ich bin geboren am 30. April 1966.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
Ich bin 1,89 m.
Wie viele?
105 kg.
105 kg?
Was für Sie heute zu uns?
Es geht schon länger, aber im Wochenende waren wir wandern.
Wir sind ungefähr 7 km im Berg hochgelaufen.
Das ging einigermaßen, aber ich habe schon gemerkt,
dass ich hier Silvettun und dann beim Runterlaufen.
Da war das echt schlimm.
Da musste ich öfters mal eine Pause machen,
weil ich in beiden Knien Schmerzen hatte.
Links, mehr, die rechte Seite.
Und jetzt habe ich auch noch einiges.
Haben Sie links, Bein, Schmerzen?
Nicht Bein, Knien, Schmerzen.
Knien, Schmerzen.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall oder Verletzung?
Nein, aber ich hatte Schmerzen.
Ich war kurzfristig mal so schlimm,
dass ich fast hingefallen wäre, aber ich hatte keinen Unfall.
Ich musste oft eine Pause machen.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Das ist genau im Kniegelenk.
Hier hinter, vorne, Leitlinke Seite, innere?
Im inneren.
Das strahlt manchmal so nach,
eher in die Kniekehle ein bisschen aus.
Okay, gut.
Können Sie ein bisschen diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dumpf oder drucken oder brennend?
Brennend nicht, aber das hatte,
seit einem Jahr ungefähr immer wieder hatte ich Knieschmerzen,
wenn ich immer ein bisschen Sport gemacht habe.
Das hat aber auch immer wieder nachgelassen,
aber wie gesagt, jetzt am Wochenende war das schlimm.
Das war eher so ein Druck und so ein ziehende Schmerz,
manchmal stechend, aber das hat einfach wehgetan.
Okay, ich trage die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus.
Ein Beispiel in den Fuß oder oberchenkel?
Nein, in den Fuß nicht, auch nicht in den oberchenkel,
das ist nur das Kniegelenk.
Das zieht so ein bisschen in die Kniekehle.
Kniekehle, hinter?
Ja, genau, aber sonst nicht.
Okay.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10 einschätzen?
Wobei 1...
Jetzt ist es sehr gering bei 1 bis 2,
aber jetzt am Wochenende war das schon sehr heftig.
Das war, würde ich sagen, bei 6 oder so, 5 bis 6.
5 bis 6, ja.
Und bei Bewegung oder bei Beleistung, Schmerzen, Verkstärk?
Ja, wenn ich hochlaufe, nicht so, aber wenn ich runterlaufe,
bei den Treffen, dann wird es richtig schlimm.
Okay.
Und Herr Brötting, gibt es bestimmt auch Stöser für diese Beschwerden?
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt?
Nee, also wie gesagt, wenn ich halt laufe und dann...
Ja, aber Sie haben diese Beschwerden ungefähr seit 6 Monaten, oder?
Ja, da hat es das erste Mal angefangen.
Aber da war das ganz leicht, da war das nicht so schlimm.
Und können wir sagen, im Laufe derzeit schlimmer geworden, oder?
Ja, das kann man so sagen.
Okay.
Und bei 6 Monaten, ich meine, sind die Schmerzen, die Beschwerden,
oder Plötze aufgetreten, oder haben sie langsam entstanden?
Ja, langsam, ja, langsam.
Und Sie haben keine bestimmten Beschwerden, oder?
Bemerkt, oder?
Nein.
Vor 6 Monaten.
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich fahre halt sehr gerne Fahrrad, schon seit vielen Jahren.
Ich fahre mit dem Fahrrad zur Arbeit und auch am Wochenende fahre ich sehr aus Fahrrad.
Am Tag 50 Kilometer am Wochenende und pro Tag ungefähr 20 Kilometer.
Also das Fahrradfahren ist ganz gut, da habe ich keine Beschwerde.
Aber jetzt vor einem halben Jahr hat es langsam angefangen beim Wandern.
Okay, verstanden.
Und haben Sie Bewegungsangstränkheiten, insbesondere im betroffenen Bereich, Bewegungs-Einschränken?
Also Bewegungs-Einschränk, wer klar, wenn Schmerzen, Beinen oder das Knie nicht so gut belasten.
Ja, das ist eben, ich muss auch eine kleine Pause machen.
Gib das etwas, was die Schmerzen lindert oder versteht?
Ja, ja, ich nehme dann Ibuprofen 400 und das geht mir relativ schnell und dann habe ich auch ein paar Stunden keine Schmerzen.
Und dann wieder?
Dann beginnt das wieder, ja.
Okay.
Und wenn ich mich schrone, wenn ich nicht belaste, wenn ich mich dann hinsetze oder mich hinlege, dann lassen die Schmerzen auf.
Und hatten Sie so sehr Beschwerden früher schon einmal, aber vor sechs Monaten?
Erstes Mal, können wir sagen.
Genau, seit sechs Monaten ist das erste Mal, davor hatte ich das nicht.
Okay.
Trittende Schmerzen, ständig oder nur, gehen Sie auf?
Nein, nicht immer.
Gelegentlich, wenn ich zu stark belaste.
Normalerweise dauert es, aber manchmal stärker, manchmal schweig können wir sagen oder?
Es ist nicht dauerhafter, es kommt immer wieder öfter.
Aber ich habe das mehr, wenn ich zu viel Sport mache oder wie gesagt beim Wandern oder wenn ich über eine längere Strecke laufe, dann kommen die Schmerzen mehr.
Okay.
Und vor sechs Monaten, haben Sie in Säkegebissen bemerkt oder?
Ob ich ein Zecken bis, nein, habe ich bisher noch nicht gehabt, nein.
Ich habe auch eine Impfung, also ich lasse mich immer sehr gerne alle Impfungen immer vom Hausarzt machen und der hat auch letztens alles kontrolliert.
Das ist alles soweit noch gut und auch die Zeckenimpfung ist noch gut.
Sind Ihnen in Betroffenen bereit?
Kribbeln, Tomhalbstgefühl oder Lehmung?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Und vielleicht haben Sie Haut oder Farbeänderung bemerkt?
Hast du, nein?
Schwellung oder Rotung oder Überwärmung?
Nein, habe ich alles nicht.
Überwärmung, Rotung?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Und Schwellung?
Keine.
Auch nicht nein, keine Schwellung, keine Rotung, keine Wärmung.
Nur haben, schmeißen?
Ja, und durchgeschmeißen.
Okay, gut, habe ich verstanden.
Ich möchte Ihnen jetzt einige Fragen so allgemeinen Gesundheitszustand stellen und haben Sie Fieber, Ubelkeit, Elbrechen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Sehr schön, das freut mich.
Und Schüttelfrost, Schweiß aus Bohe, Nacht?
Nein, habe ich alles nicht.
Ja, das ist ein gutes Zeichen.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder bei dem Wasserlassen?
Nein, das klappt noch alles gut.
Ich bin auch regelmäßig beim Urologen, der sagt auch, die Prostzatei ist in Ordnung.
Ich brauche deswegen keine Tabletten.
Alles gut.
Okay, gut.
Und in letzter Zeit insbesondere haben Sie Schwierigkeiten, Eins- oder Suchschlafen?
Also beim Schlafen? Nein, nein.
Schlafen ist klar wunderbar, ich kann wie ein Bär schlafen.
Ja, okay, gut, sehr gut.
Und wie ist das Petit?
Ich meine, in letzter Zeit haben Sie ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, eigentlich immer gleich bleiben.
Abpetit ist gut, manchmal zu gut.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ein bisschen übergebiet.
Okay, gut.
Und leiden Sie ein chronischer Erkrankungen?
Sie haben gesagt, mit Prostzate haben Sie ein Problem, oder?
Und auch sehr viel.
Nein, wir haben kein Problem.
Der Urologen sagt, das ist alles in Ordnung.
Als chronischer Erkrankung habe ich einen Bluthochdruck.
Da nehme ich auch Tabletten.
Seit wann haben Sie?
Seit ungefähr 10 Jahren.
10 Jahren, mhm.
Okay, und gibt es nur oder nur das?
Nein, nur der Bluthochdruck.
Und mit Prostzate ein bisschen, können wir, könnten wir ein bisschen beschreiben.
Was ist Problem mit Prostzate?
Mit Prostzate habe ich kein Problem.
Ich habe doch schon gesagt, der Urologen hat gesagt, das ist alles in Ordnung.
Ich gehe nur regelmäßig zur Kontrolle.
Okay, okay, okay.
Ich habe falsch verstanden.
Okay, gut.
Der Urologen sagt, das ist alles in Ordnung, kein Problem.
Ja, sehr schön.
Ich gehe immer zur Vorsorge.
Ja, ja.
Und sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, ich hatte mal einen Leistungsbruch auf der rechten Seite,
aber das ist auch schon über 20 Jahre her.
Sonst habe ich keine Operation.
Ja, okay.
Und war die Operation komplikationslos?
Ja, ja, ja.
War alles gut, da habe ich keine Probleme mit.
Sehr schön.
Und nennen Sie regelmäßig Urte elegante Medikamente ein?
Ja, für den Blutdruck.
Ja.
Gegenblutdruck.
Welche Medikamente?
Das sind die Candesatan 16 mg.
Morgens, ein Tablet.
Morgens und abends, jeweils einetan.
Und gibt es noch oder nur Candesatan?
Nur Candesatan.
Okay, gut.
Und haben Sie allergenen Verträglichkeiten, Herr Brett?
Nein.
Als aller Kind glücklicherweise bisher nicht.
Zum Beispiel gegen Jot, Kontrastmittel, Medikamente.
Nein, nein, nein.
Darf ich fragen, ob Sie rauchen?
Nein, also ich hatte im Studium, also bis zu meinem Jahr,
im 30. Lebensjahr habe ich ein bisschen geraucht, aber dann nicht mehr.
Okay.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol elegante oder regelmäßig?
Ja, ich trinke gerne mal ein Bier.
Ein Fleisch Bier täglich, oder?
Einfach mehr, das kann schon auch mal 2, 3 Stück am Tag sein.
Okay.
Im Wochenende ist es manchmal etwas mehr.
Und nehmen Sie bitte das, nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Hatten oder haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen, nein.
Ja.
Keiner Biskot, kein Eier oder anything.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ja, schön.
Ja, das ist, ich vermute aber, das ist eine Routinefrage, okay?
Erst mal.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich trinke lieber Bier, das, ich hieß mir schon,
ein bisschen runterzukommen.
Okay, verstanden.
Und jetzt kommen wir zur Sozial- und familiärstürzion.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und wir haben einen Sohn.
Der ist circa...
Ist gesund?
Ja, der ist 25, der ist gesund.
Ja, gut.
Und was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Lehrer.
Lehrer.
Und beide Arbeit, haben Sie viel Stress, oder?
Ja, natürlich, immer wieder.
Wir kennen das ja mit Schülern zu arbeiten und dann mit anderen Kollegen und der Schule.
Das kann manchmal auch, wenn es Spaß macht, sehr belastend sein, ja.
Okay.
Und leben Ihre Enten noch?
Nein, nein.
Die sind leider schon verstorben, ja.
Und darf ich fragen, warum?
Woran?
Mein Vater hatte leider einen Herzinfarkt.
Und wie alt war er?
Mein Vater?
Der war 82 Jahre alt.
82?
Mhm.
Und Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter hatte leider Brustkrebs.
Und sie ist auch vor zwei Jahren verstorben.
Vor zwei Jahren, ja.
Ich schulde mir leid und meine Heilung ist beileid.
Und haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich habe nur eine Schwester.
Und ist sie gesund?
Ja, sie ist ein Schwitter, aber ich glaube, sie hat Diabetes.
Und ist auch immer regelmäßig beim Arzt.
Ja, so geht es ja eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja, gut.
Okay.
Und zum Schluss möchte ich Ihnen noch ein paar Kursefragen stellen, Herr Brateng.
Sind Sie vorstellend geimpft?
Ja, habe ich ja begonnen.
Okay, sehr schön.
Mein Hausarzt kontrolliert das.
Ja, und waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Beziehungweise in den Tropen?
Nein, in letzter Zeit nicht.
Wie lange ist das hier?
Zeigern Jahre haben wir mal in Kenia, für zwei, drei Wochen.
Aber das war alles in Ordnung.
Sehr schön.
Ich möchte jetzt auf Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden zurückkommen, Herr Brateng.
Und hatten Sie aufgrund Ihrer Beschwerden einen Arzt aufgesucht?
Ja, ich war einmal, ich gehe ja regelmäßig zu meinem Hausarzt,
ich kenne das auch.
Er hat schon öfter gesagt, ich soll mal zum Orthopädem,
aber ich habe es ja noch nie beim Orthopädem,
weil die Schmerzen nicht so schlimm waren,
aber jetzt ist das schon sehr heftig.
Aber es gibt keine Diagnose, oder?
Nein, bisher noch nicht.
Und mit Apparativ-Machnahmen vor, haben Sie durchgeführt, oder?
Nein, bisher war das noch nicht.
Wir sind mit einer Messer fertig, ich glaube,
dass ich alle wichtigen Informationen habe,
Frau Brateng.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen, oder haben Sie noch etwas zu fragen?
Nein, also vielleicht können Sie ja heute eine Abklärung machen
und mir sagen, ob ich mir Sorgen machen muss,
weil ich will keine Operation, ich bin noch nicht so alter, Herr Dr.
Ja, natürlich, Sie haben Red,
und Ihre Sorge und Ihre Angst sind absolut verständlich,
aber im Moment kann ich noch nicht genau sagen.
Zunächst werde ich ein paar körperliche Unterhörungen durchführen
und gegebenenfalls mit Apparativveranlassenden Massnahmen
und dann auch genau sagen.
Dafür traue ich schon ganz Ihnen, Herr Dr.
Sie sind der Fachmann. Vielen Dank.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch Fragen?
Ich habe morgen Stifelkeit in der Knie.
Ja, ich muss mich natürlich am Anfang ein bisschen bewegen,
bestimmt schon, aber das ist jetzt nicht so schlimm,
dann wird es auch besser.
Über den Tag habe ich einen Anzellen.
Zuerst noch eine Frage.
Haben Sie Instabilitätsgefühl oder Knacken bemerkt?
Knacken jetzt nicht, aber Instabilität,
wenn ich Schmerzen habe, dann kann ich mich richtig auftreten
und dann muss ich auch eine kurze Pause machen.
Danke. Darf ich fragen?
Wenn ich nicht falsch verstanden habe,
Sie haben mehr als runtergehend Schmerzen,
als Treppen steigen, oder?
Mehr beim runtergehen oder beim Treppen absteigen.
Danke.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich habe keine Fragen, das ist sehr tischam.
Ich habe eine Frage, habe ich kurz.
Haben Sie Ihr Bein oder Ihr Gelenk
vorstellendig beugen oder einstrecken?
Wenn ich keine Schmerzen habe,
dann kann ich mich ganz gut beugen.
Aber wenn die Schmerzen da sind,
dann habe ich Schwierigkeiten, dann geht es nicht.
Okay, danke.
Angemieren.
Ja, okay.
Dann angeln.
Hallo, guten Tag Herr Oberatz.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen
und möchte Ihnen diesen Patient vorstellen,
wenn Sie, haben Sie, wo seid ihr?
Aber natürlich, bitte schön.
Ja, okay.
Danke schön.
Ich möchte Sie um einen 59-jährigen Patienten
Herr Felix Breitlingen.
Breitlingen.
Und 1,89 m groß und ca. 105 kg schwer.
Der Patient stellte,
dass sie heute bei uns schwer sind,
ungefähr 6 Monate,
aber in letzter Zeit verstärken.
Bechtehende, zunehmende,
im linken Seite,
Knieschmerzen,
und die Schmerzen sind druckend,
stehend und manchmal sichend,
könne wir sagen.
Und der Patient gab an,
dass die Schmerzen in Knie,
nein, in Oberchenkel,
und ein bisschen,
kniekele,
ja, kniekele,
aufstrahlen.
Und die Schmerzintensität wurde laut seinen Angaben
mit 5 bis 6
von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala bewertet.
Und die Schmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten,
und im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Außer berichtet der Patient,
dass er früher nicht Beschwerden mit gehabt habe.
Es ist das erste Mal,
natürlich vor 6 Monaten.
Und das 2. Klagte der Patient über,
ja, über,
keine Probleme,
ja,
und die Fragen,
die Fragen,
Neuse-Emesis-Fiva-Stelfrost
und Würde-Ferneint,
die Vegetarien-Emesis ist unauffällig,
kann ich sagen.
Und an Furarikanan-Kumbien leidet der Patient
arterielle Hypertonie seit 10 Jahren.
An einer, an einer arteriellen Hypertonie.
An einer arteriellen Hypertonie seit 10 Jahren.
Und der Patient ist vor 20 Jahren,
wegen einer Ingenialherne,
operiert worden,
rechte Seite.
Und der Patient nimmt Kardesartan 10 mg morgens und abends.
Und der Patient hat keine Allergenie,
keine Unvertegligkeiten.
Und noch,
noch in Anamnese,
der Patient ist nicht rauher,
aber ein oder zwei Fleischbiathekli
konsumiert, kann ich sagen.
Und dringend Konsum würde Fernneint auch.
Und der Sozialanamnese gab der Patient an,
dass er verheiratet ist und ein gesundes Sohn hat.
Eine gesunden Sohn, ja, Entschuldigung.
Sohn hat, ja.
Und der Patient arbeitet als Lehrer
und beide Arbeiten hat viel Stress.
Ja, und der Vater und der Mutter,
der Vater,
der Patientin,
ist im Alter von 82 Jahren
an Myokart infakt verstoben
und seine Mutter ist
an Mama Karzinom verstorben auch.
Und der Patient hat eine Schwester
und sie leidet an Diabetes mellitus.
Und im Status Reiseanamnese
und andere Anamnese sind unauffällig,
kann ich sagen.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und Perdachdiagnose, oder?
Die sind der Arzt, wenn sie fertig sind.
Ja, und die Angaben.
Perdach und äußern natürlich.
Die Angaben deuten am ersten auf eine
Kreuzband-Praktü.
Meniscus.
Jetzt war es jetzt, Kreuzband oder Meniscus?
Das sind zwei unterschiedliche Sachen.
Ach, Kreuzband.
Nicht verwechselnd.
Kreuzband ist etwas anderes,
Meniscus ist etwas anderes,
so wie bei einem Kollegen vorhin,
Sie müssen diese Definitionen genau kennen.
Ich bin nicht sicher.
Aber wir können.
Und Meniscus ist das.
Da haben Sie die eine Familie noch mal genauer.
Nein, Kreuzband-Praktü.
Ich denke, die Franzialldiagnostisch kommen,
wir sagen Meniscus.
Da müssen Sie sagen, meine Verdachtdiagnose ist,
man sagt, Kreuzband-Praktur,
kenne ich jetzt nicht, man sagt Kreuzband-Riss.
Und weitere Differentialdiagnose wären Meniscus-Riss.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es den Blick auf Meniscus-Praktur gibt.
Ich weiß nicht, muss ich noch mal gucken.
Meniscus-Riss.
Sie gehen eher von einem Kreuzband-Problem aus.
Aber er hatte auch beiden Seiten,
hatte doch Schmerzen gehabt.
Er hatte jetzt auch beiden Seiten Kreuzband-Riss.
Ja, ich bin nicht sicher,
aber mein Vater hat keinen Fußball.
Er spielt kein Fußball.
Er fährt nur Fahrrad.
Akute Belastung hatte jetzt nichts.
Aber kann natürlich sein.
Woran denken Sie noch?
Was ist die Differentialdiagnose?
Differentialdiagnose,
ich kann es sagen,
Meniscus und vielleicht
Ostostar kommen.
Er freut erst mal langsam.
Das ist ein Mann mit Übergewicht.
Das ist ein Mann, der wird alt.
Das ist ein Mann, der hat Belastungen am Knie.
Und der hat einen Job, der steht ja meistens.
Was ist das, was man im hohen Alter sehr oft hat,
was kommt sehr häufig vor,
an den Kniegelenken?
Ja, mein Kollege.
Vielleicht können wir sagen, Ostropos,
wegen Ostropos,
von Artros.
Ostropos ist meistens bei den Frauen.
Was ist an dem Gehnenk?
Genatrose, ja.
Genatrose, das ist der Begriff.
Eine Genatrose.
Ja, können Sie bereich,
betroffenen bereich und
die Patientin hat
Spezifikbeschwerden.
Sie können dafür,
wie Sie das erzählen,
meine Verdatzdiagnose war,
dass es eine Genatrose ist.
Der ist ja der Eingradung,
Grat 1, 2, 3.
Dass es eine leichte Artrose angefangen hat
und jetzt etwas progradient ist
und sie etwas verschlechtert.
Welche Diagnostik machen Sie,
um das festzustellen?
Ja, um meine Verdatzdiagnose zu bestätigen,
würde ich einige Massnahmen durchführen.
Was?
Was würde ich wissen?
Was jetzt am Massnahmen, kann ich sagen,
ausführlich und untersuchen, durchführen zum Beispiel.
Was machen Sie mit dem Knie?
Sie wollen jetzt wissen,
dass es mehrere Diagnosen sind,
von Natrose, Kreuzwand, Miniskurs und so weiter.
Welche Diagnostik
machen Sie als Erstes?
Natürlich körperliche Untersuchungen, ganz klar.
Mit körperlichen,
bei der körperlichen Untersuchung,
Sie meinen?
Neurologisch untersuchen durchführen,
körperlich.
Mit einer Bewegung
gibt es noch
Einschränkungen.
Genau.
Gibt es den Begriff des Schubladenphänomens?
Auch hier gelangt, wenn man an der Warte zieht.
Haben Sie einen Orthopäden unter uns?
Ja, ich werde
einen Orthopäden, der sich aufhört.
Das ist das beste.
Vielleicht sollten Sie das auch angucken.
Das sind die einfache Methoden.
Wenn man wissen möchte, welche Richtung geht das,
dann normalerweise bolgt der Patient erliegt,
macht er eine Beuge, sie setzen sich auf den Fuß
und ziehen an den Unterschenkel.
Natürlich, dass der Lenk nach vorne kommt
und der Schmerz hat,
dann ist es ein Hinweis, dass es vielleicht doch der Kreuzband ist.
Diese einfachen Methoden
sollte man vielleicht auch wissen.
Aber das Erste ist, was man macht,
natürlich, was jeder Orthopäde erst mal macht,
eine Röntgenaufnahme.
Eine ganz normale Röntgenaufnahme.
Da sieht man den Gelenkspalt,
die Vorflächen, die Kniegelenke, zueinander liegen.
Sie sehen auch, ob da eine Arprose vorliegt.
Meistens reicht eine ganz normale Röntgenaufnahme.
Sie können sagen,
Druckschmerz gibt es
oder nicht,
medial und lateral.
Ja, genau.
Das machen Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Aber jetzt bei der Apparativen Diagnostik Röntgen.
Wenn Sie wissen möchten,
ist da ein Miniskursdresse oder ein Kreuzbanddresse.
Welche Untersuchung ist da die erste Wahl?
Oder die Diagnostik der Wahl?
Um Weichtagstrukturen besser zu sehen
und zu beurteilen?
Die Erste ist die Erste.
Wir fallen noch
2 differenzial Diagnosen ein.
Beim Knie, wo haben wir das noch denken?
Welche differenzial Diagnose?
Die Kniekele.
Was ist in der Kniekele?
Andere.
Was gibt es da, was manchmal Schmerzen machen kann?
Was weiß ich?
Ich erinnere nicht da.
Das ist wie ein kleiner Ball.
Eine Bursitis.
Eine Bursitis,
aber das habe ich nicht gemeint.
Jawohl, wer ist das?
Eine Baker-Züste.
Was ist eine Baker-Züste?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ein Baker-Züste.
Was ist eine Baker-Züste?
Woran muss man noch denken?
Welche weitere differenzial Diagnose?
Ein Baker-Züste.
Was ist normal, dass die Wademuskel oder die Oberchenkelmuskel
einen Muskelriss haben?
Und was kann bei einem Sportler passieren?
Immerwider, wenn er ein Trauma hat,
wenn er hinfällt, wenn er einen Stoß in die Wade bekommt
oder immer nur sitzt.
Was passiert am Unterschenkel und der Kniekele?
langen Reisen hat man das so nach Operationen kann es auch.
Die tiefen Stromböse.
Lauter, Lauter Frau Dejane, lauter.
Die tiefen Venöstromböse.
Tiefe, eine TvT.
Ja, TvT.
Die tiefen Venöse Stromböse.
Genau, eine TvT, tiefe Beinvenenstromböse.
Ja, ja.
TvT ist die Abkürzung.
Also eine Komboose müssen Sie natürlich auch immer denken.
Ja, ich habe gefragt, der Patient hat keine Überwärmung, Rotung oder Tumor.
Das ist richtig, aber das ist jetzt nicht der Kopf.
Ja, ja.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Und Therapie, wir können etwas sagen.
etwas sagen. Mein Patient hat Obergewicht. Ich empfehle den Patienten Gewichtreduktion
und es ist richtig. Was spritzen Sie intra-artikulär? Was für Materialien? Oder welche Stoffe?
Platine, wie ich weiß nicht.
Sie haben gesagt, intra-artikuläre Injektion. Was geben Sie denn?
Steroid.
Steroid, was noch?
Und gibt es noch Corticosteroid?
Nein, nicht nichts. Doktor Einstein hat es. Tior Lironsäure.
Aha, die Lironika ist jetzt türkisch.
Tior Lironsäure.
Genau, wir machen Deutsch unter euch. Tior Lironsäure.